love you with us welcome lovey thanks so
much for having me it's amazing to be
here with the Rival chess website or now
in a few months potentially pending a
few signatures here and there uh all one
giant happy Monopoly of Chess companies
right Tanya we're all one family now
I know we're all caught are we are we
are we all work colleagues now is that
is that how this works I don't know how
this works but it's exciting I made the
same joke to David when we recorded a
podcast together uh our podcast also a
lot of fun uh and I've been enjoying
watching the coverage of of the event as
always
lovey uh were you at all surprised when
the announcement of chesscom and chess
24 came out
yeah
I mean maybe maybe you weren't I don't
know I I I had absolutely I was
absolutely shocked I was on my way back
from the FDX crypto Cup in Miami so I
had been with the team with the chess
2014 for a good 10 days and I had zero
idea what was coming on and I was in
Dubai in transit and I opened Twitter
and I see this tweet and and
I'm just like what
yeah listen I have conversations about
once every three months with Danny
wrench where we just talk about the
future talk about the current talk about
you know if there's anything either one
of us can do better it's sort of like a
friendly chat it's not even a company
chat he never me never obviously never
mentioned this once and I was like oh
okay and you know what else that whole
tweet that they put out with the
conversation with uh with Magnus yeah it
it was so it was weird it wasn't it
wasn't like a crazy big announcement you
know like when a Esports athlete joins
an org like I'm now joining it it was
just kind of like yeah here's us talking
so this is happening it's pretty cool by
it I was just kind of like this is
massive news but it was super chill for
the biggest merger that Jess has seen
yeah well we don't we the thing is we
don't have a lot of companies also I
don't know if we have crazy billion
dollar valuations chess is a pretty new
space but yeah it was it was huge uh and
we'll see what the future holds
obviously there's good and there's bad
when these kinds of things happen and I
think 2021 was such a massive year for
chess trying to scale but also for
bringing in sponsors that there's a
chance that in in places we bit off a
bit more than we could chew I'm even
experiencing that myself with uh
obviously the slow decline so we might
have gotten some people employed last
year that obviously may not be involved
as much in the future that's just sort
of that's just sort of the way it goes
so while it is kind of a joke and it is
exciting there's also some serious
implications for people they uh may or
may not obviously have their work
contracts extended so that's kind of the
serious part of it right we don't want
to just kind of gloss over that but uh
we'll see we'll see what it means for
the future